GET IT OFF THE
GALLAGHER.
ROMANOV WITH A SHOT.
[ Whistle ]
RIGHT ON.
HERE'S NICK SUZUKI TAKES THE
SHOT AND IT'S GLOVED BY HUNT WI.
RIGHT ON!
JAKE A
DALLAS FOR THE WON THE NOR
ROMANOV.
BROKEN UP BY McKEGG.
TURNOVER RIGHT HERE.
MISSED PASS KIND OF BACK
OUT.LL
THIS GREAT SPEED COMES FROM. INS
SO MUCH ATTENTION AT THE
NET.
HEL SEE WHO'S GOING TO
LIGHT THE LAMP FIRST HERE IN
THE SECOND PERIOD.
ZIBANEJAD ON THE PUCK PLAY
IT IS OFF THE BOARDS TO IT'S GLY
SHESTERKIN.
THERE'S A GOOD START TO THEATCHY
BOOT THIS INTO THE NET.
WE'LL GET A BETTER LOOK
PAQUETTE TAKES THE HIT FROM
REAVES.
TIPPEDED ALL
SPORTS.DS ON.
FIELDS IT FOR PANARIN WITH
>> Garry: WHEN YOU'VE TAKEN
LOTS OF PENALTIES, BOYOY GARRY
GALLEY WITH THE OF PUCK
THE FORD
SEE IF HE CAN FIND ANDERSON
ON THA
WITH 6 SECONDS LEFT IN THE
POWER PLAY.ACK AGAIN.
JEFF PETRY RELOADS!AROUND FOR T.
JOSH ANDERSON FINISHING HHE DID.
HE DIDN'T DUST IT OFF.
HE TRANSITIONED IT RIGHT
ACROS HE FOOLS HIM, PULLS IT
ACROSS ON THE BACKHAND BACK
ING THE ASSIST AS WELL
THE
MIDDLE TO ZIBANEJAD.
VERY SIMILAR LOOK THAT HE
HAD ON THET
KEEP PLUGGING AWAY HERE.
>> John: HERE COMES PANARIN
WITH IT. IT.
ZIBANEJAD, GOOD JOB THERE
TRYING TO BURN THE CLOCK.
PUCK.
YOU'VE GOT THREE, FOUR
CANADIEN PLAY